hey this is presh tollwacker
today I learned that 69 is the only
natural number whose square
4761 and Cube 328
509 uses every decimal digit from 0 to 9
exactly once
to visualize this in another way
the cube has six digits and the square
has four digits so together there are
ten digits between the square and the
cube
and there are exactly 10 digits which
correspond to the digits going from zero
to nine used exactly once
this is a very nice mathematical
property of 69
but it's an interesting fact that it's
the only number with this property
so how can we prove that this is true
to get started let's compute 2 squared
which is 4 and 2 cubed which is eight
we can see the square has one digit the
cube has one digit now in order to get
all of the digits from 0 to 9 between
the square and the cube we're going to
need a total of 10 digits so here we
have only two digits between the square
and the cube and we need 10 digits so 2
is too small of a number
so we'll try a larger number
what if we try 11 squared and 11 cubed
now the square has three digits and the
cube has four digits
so this is a total of seven digits and
once again this is too small we need 10
digits
so what if we compute 45 squared and 45
cubed the square has four digits and the
cube has five digits so we have nine
digits here but we need 10 digits so we
need to be slightly larger
so we keep Computing 46 will also be
slightly too small
but once we get to 47 we have just the
right number of digits there are four
digits in the square and there are six
digits in the cube
but this is not a solution because some
of the digits are repeated so we can
start testing from 48 squared and 48
cubed so that's a lower bound
now by the same token there are going to
be numbers whose square and cubes have
too many digits
so what numbers will that be
well let's say we take a hundred squared
and a hundred cubed
we're going to count that this is a
total of 12 digits so if we have 12
digits between the square and the cube
even if we get all of the digits from 0
to 9 we will get some repeated digits so
we have too many digits here
so we will check 99 squared and 99 cubed
and voila this is exactly 10 digits now
99 is not an answer because the digit 9
is repeated in the cube
but we know that every number larger
than this will not work
so we can stop testing at 98.
so we really need to do the following
for a number between 48 and 98 inclusive
let's say the number is n we compute N
squared and N cubed and we test if the
digits in N squared plus the digits in N
cubed are exactly the set of digits from
0 to 9.
so that's not too hard to do
computationally you could even do it by
calculator or by pencil and paper
but we are in the computer age and of
course you don't even have to write your
own code
so I asked Google bard this prompt write
a program in Python to find all numbers
whose square and Cube contains every
digit from 0 to 9 without repetition
so it gave me some code in Python and it
actually said the output will be 69. but
you always want to use code with caution
so let's look at this code in a little
bit more detail because it's not doing
exactly what we want it to do even
though it got us the right answer
so here's the output from Google bard
and I'll mention I use Google bard
because chat GPT didn't give me code
that actually worked and gave the
correct answer so this is the case where
actually Google barred was something I
really appreciate it
so it wasn't perfect but it was in the
right direction so let's Analyze This
code so the first thing it's doing I set
to test for all numbers so decided to
test for a very large range of numbers
so we don't need to go ahead and do that
we can actually just limit our range
because there's no point in testing
numbers that are outside of the ranges
that we already defined
so we only want to test from 48 to 98.
so let X be the range 48.99 1 and we
want n in X so we'll replace this code
now we've replaced number with n so
wherever we have number we want to
change that to be n
so we'll go ahead and change the code
now what do we need to notice look at
this line of code digits is equal to the
set of the string n plus the string
square plus the string Cube while this
is a little bit of a problem we only
want the digits in the square and the
cube we don't want the digits in the
number n itself so let's remove that
from the code
so we get rid of that
and now we have code that we can
actually test out and see how it works
so now an amazing thing we can do is we
can check our code and visualize it in
Python tutor
so we first defined fine numbers and now
the first number we're going to check is
going to be the number 48. so we're
going to compute its Square we're going
to compute its Cube then we're going to
get the set of digits from the square
and Cube and see if that set of digits
has exactly the 10 digits from 0 to 9
this does not so now we're going to
increment to 49. we do the same thing we
check the square we check the cube we
check the set of digits from the square
and the cube we see if that is exactly
10 digits it's not so then we increment
and we're going to keep doing this
and now the computer program this is the
beauty it just checks everything for us
it goes through this process and
eventually we're going to get to the
number 69 which is going to be the only
solution and from there we're going to
check all the other possible values
and we're going to see that none of the
other values will be a solution so we
let the program run it checks all the
relevant values and we get that 69 is
the only solution and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign